The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So yesterday we went
through quantum mechanics
and discussed the solutions
of the Schrodinger equation.
We started with the
one-dimensional problem
is the quantum well.
Two-dimensional problem-- now
we call them a quantum wire.
And then, say you can
extend that to a 3D--
that's easy.
And then I gave a
harmonic wave solution
for the harmonic oscillator.
I gave you the result. But I
said I have my way to solve it.
And then I don't have a way
to solve rigid rotor my way.
Maybe you can find it.
And the electron-- we
give the results, right?
And, in fact, I said that
you can also do the electron.
And I know that you
can do it and find out.
So for different
problems, the difference
is really the potential in
the Schrodinger equation
plus a boundary condition
that [INAUDIBLE] determine
why some of the solution,
like quantum well,
the energy level is a
proportion of n square,
the harmonic oscillator
is the proportion of u n,
and the electrons u
atoms is 1 over n square.
Those are because of the
constraint of different shapes
of the potentials.
And then why we discussed
1D and 2D problems?
The important
message that we get
is, if it's a 1
degree of freedom,
one-dimensional problem,
we have one quantum number.
And two-dimensional problem,
we'll have to quantum numbers.
And three-dimensional
problem, like atoms,
we have three quantum numbers.
And, of course, later
on we add the spin
because that's not something
you can get from the Schrodinger
equation.
And then, quantum
state is each set
of [INAUDIBLE]
unique combinations
of those quantum numbers
give you one quantum state.
The problem is sometimes
different quantum states
have the same energy.
So when we can, we
say-- when states
have same-- different
states have same energy,
those states are degenerate.
And we can count the
degeneracy of those states.
And those are later on
important because, essentially,
when we do--
they count the
number of particles--
like we did in first
chapter, first two lectures--
we need counting.
We need to do the
counting correctly.
So degeneracy is later
on going to be evolved
into a density of states.
And spin is something
we cannot easily--
we cannot get from
Schrodinger equation.
I have to go to relativistic.
And-- but the--
for electrons, it's a 1/2
spin, positive minus 1/2 half.
And those are fermions.
And photons, pholons,
are molecules
that are uncharged bosons.
And for fermions, the
Pauli Exclusion Principle
says each quantum state can
have maximum of one particle.
So if it's a fermion
particle, each quantum state
can only have one
to the maximum.
You [INAUDIBLE] So
that's easy to count.
And for boson,
each quantum state
can have an infinite number.
So this is-- when you think
about this harmonic oscillator,
the energy is n times h bar.
And h bar mu--
actually, h bar omega--
the n could be 0, 1, 2, 3.
Those [INAUDIBLE] many
[INAUDIBLE] n numbers.
So this is what we talked about.
And in those examples, the
wave function are confined.
When I have a quantum
well or quantum wire,
the wave function is in this
space that I'm discussing.
When I have an atom,
the wave function
is limited to
surrounding the nuclei.
So, oscillator--
that's the local.
So this is what we
discussed so far.
And today, where I'm going is--
I'm going to put
the atoms together
to have solid crystals.
And how-- this
putting them together,
how they will change the energy
states in what we discussed?
So what are we going
to discuss today
is the energy levels in solids.
Particularly, I'll
focus on electron today.
And, hopefully, by the
end of the lecture,
you will appreciate
why we have metals.
We have semiconductors.
We have insulators.
These are all daily encounters.
But until you have
this quantum picture,
you really can't explain.
And so we have metals,
semiconductors, and insulators.
And one very useful mathematical
theorem that I introduced today
is the so-called Bloch Theorem.
It's a-- this is a
theorem that applies when
the potential is a periodic.
So when I deal with
crystals, the atoms
are arranged in
periodic fashion.
And because of
this periodicity, I
can solve the problem even
though the crystal is--
an ideal crystal is an infinite
periodic arrangement of atoms.
And because of periodicity,
I can fold all the problems
into one period.
And that's very beautiful.
And, in fact, the
Bloch Theorem is
valid for all waves,
all periodic structure
when you have wave
[INAUDIBLE] inside.
And when you deal with the
heat conduction equation,
or when you deal
with the transport--
when there is a
temperature gradient,
this is no longer
valid or diffusion.
And for several years
I've been trying
to say, what's a corresponding
CRM in the diffusion regime?
And because when
I do a composite
and those kind of problems,
transport problems--
a composite that has many,
many different materials--
[INAUDIBLE] think about two,
an A and a B. My simplest is--
I take a [INAUDIBLE].
Can I solve that
[INAUDIBLE] problem
and yet to be representative
that I'm dealing
with the whole structure?
So those are the things that
are a good question to ask.
And so let's start.
We say-- we're dealing
with electrons.
And in the last
lecture, yesterday,
we deal with the
electron when we say
our model is, I have an atom.
And I have electron.
If you'll recall, at the end
we show the wave functions.
We showed and computed
the different n equals 1.
Say, for example,
the wave function
with three quantum number,
1, 0, 0, and, of course,
electron spin--
that's an increase of 1.
[INAUDIBLE] equals 0.
M equals 0.
The [INAUDIBLE] functions
is the lowest energy level,
spherical wave function
that [INAUDIBLE]
And so this is, of course, you
can have higher-- other wave
functions and combinations.
And now, my question is,
what about this is a simple--
you think about hydrogen atom.
What happens to
hydrogen molecule
when I put two atoms
close together?
So in the case of
single atom, I have--
this n equals 1 energy
level and n equals 2.
In the hydrogen model,
we have the energy
is degenerate is minus 13.6
electron volts over n square.
36-- 13.6 electron volts is
also another energy unit.
Sometimes people use it
[INAUDIBLE] 1 [INAUDIBLE]..
And-- so this is, of
course, we say degenerate
because I have three
quantum lumber,
n l m and plus the
spin quantum number.
So if I have one hydrogen
atom-- let's say atom,
the electron sits in
the lowest energy level.
And now, if I put
2 hydrogen atoms--
so I have 1 hydrogen atom.
Those are the electron
wave function.
If you recall, it's a spherical.
And I have another-- so
this is 1 hydrogen atom.
And I have another
hydrogen atom and electron
is spherical wave function.
Now, when they interact with
each other to form a molecule,
the electron wave
function start to overlap.
And the Pauli Exclusion
Principle could come in.
You can't do that.
Now, the two electron--
each hydrogen has one electron.
The two electron cannot
have the same wave function
because of the Pauli Exclusion.
And one quantum state
doesn't take two electrons.
So what happens?
And they will have to
modify their quantum state
and split it.
And then the
splitting gives you--
if you go to solve
the wave function,
you'll say, OK,
this is the atom--
hydrogen atom.
In one case, it's wave
function is more each one
separated from each other.
And the other case--
this wave function
is the probability
of finding electrons, remember,
if you do complex conjugate.
And the other case, you
have the wave function more
surrounding them.
This is a sigma bond.
Covalent bonding-- and
that's the strongest,
the lower energy.
This is the anti-bond,
sigma star higher energy.
So what happens is
that this energy--
the single energy
of our atom now--
because of Pauli
Exclusion Principle,
when they have two electrons
for the identical states,
they can't do it.
So they split into two small--
with separation of
the two energy levels.
So the states split
into from one to two.
So this is the
higher energy level.
This is lower energy level.
Now with this, I can
ask the question,
what if I put the hydrogen
atom into a chain, not just
a molecule?
And if I have any--
N hydrogen atom,
what's going to happen?
They are capital N,
not like this small n.
If I have capital
N atoms, what's
going to happen to increase one?
AUDIENCE: The molecules
[INAUDIBLE] keep splitting?
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's split into N energy levels.
And, similarly, n equals 2--
so basically if I have--
you will have energy split
into each of this [INAUDIBLE]
are split into energy level.
And, now, of course,
that depends on here
is, how large is this spread?
And this too could
actually overlap.
This is originally 13.6
eV divided by n square.
So this is a few eV.
If this split didn't start
to overlap with each other,
you have almost a continuous.
Those are relatively
small level of separation
between energy levels.
So this gives us a
precursor to what
happens if I have a
one-dimensional atomic chain.
So-- crystals--
let's take it bigger.
So my simplest picture is a
one-dimensional arrangement
of crystals are the periodic
arrangement of atoms.
So I have periodic
And the potential is a periodic.
So around each
atom, the electron--
recall, the quantum potential
is negative [INAUDIBLE] over R.
So, here in the--
when I close to atom,
the potential is lowest.
And in between is
the higher potential.
So I have periodical
potential field to the charge.
So now we want to find out--
we already got some idea this
is what's going to happen.
The energy is going to split.
And we want to find the
splitted energy levels.
And we're going to solve the
Schrodinger equation for that.
And, in fact, that there are--
really, this problem, you can
look at it from three pictures.
Let me explain briefly.
The first picture I read, it
said the atomic [INAUDIBLE]
overlapping.
So if I draw-- if I
simplify this potential,
I get a square rather
than what I draw 1 over R.
So here I have [INAUDIBLE]--
So this is a
[INAUDIBLE] periodic.
That's another way I
model those potential.
The real atoms is never--
just so this is square.
It's-- like I say, this
is very much depend on--
the energy level depends
on the potential shape.
And, of course,
if I do a square,
then I have the picture.
I have quantum wells.
If it's an infinite potential,
I have this standing wave
for electrons quantum wells.
And-- but say this is a
normally not an infinite.
They are certain height.
So it turns out from wave
mechanics perspective--
later on, when we
do chapter 5, you'll
see the wave can tunnel
from one side to the other.
So they start
[INAUDIBLE] overlapping.
And then the quantum mechanic
Pauli Explosion Principle
say you can't overlap
the quantum state.
So they will split at this--
this will split into, again,
the ones that we described here,
when atom of those
start to overlap.
And these are the ones--
this is a one
picture, I say, OK, we
start thinking about the
quantum well picture.
And the other picture is, I
have a free electron moving
in space.
And when free electron moving in
space and when they start to--
so those are the electron
with the higher energy.
They start to see
a bump potential
underneath it, a periodic
bump potential underneath it.
And, in that case,
what happened is if--
some of you may
have the experience
using the interference filter in
your lab-- optical interference
filters in your lab.
So that's an optical
wave comes in.
And the interference filter,
is a typically periodical layer
deposition with different
refractive index.
So what happens is,
then, some of the wave
will transmit through,
others reflect back.
That's why I say you
can get lateral lines
in the interference filter.
So the reflected back ones are
the ones that do not exist.
Those are the ones--
the wave cannot exist.
So this is the gap
here in the solid.
This is a-- what this leads to
is a semiconductor with a band
gap.
So you have this two picture.
And the third picture is what
I'm going to actually solve.
I solve the
Schrodinger equation--
another solution tells us
without the energy level.
And all this will converge
into what we said already.
So, here I have the this
is the periodicity T.
And let's say under
my picture here,
I'm going to take a
one-unit cell, one period,
and trying to solve
the Schrodinger
equation in that period.
I can take any period.
So I put my coordinate--
here is my origin
of the coordinate.
And this is 0.
And this is the x direction.
And here is a.
And here is-- let's
say-- because this
is on the other side--
this is a minus b.
And from minus b to a,
that's an-- add together
is my period T.
And I want to solve this
Schrodinger equation
in this one period.
But I want to represent the
whole structure as a periodic.
My potential is repeating
from every minus b to a.
So here, the potential
is at the bottom.
Let's say the potential is 0.
Here the potential is u0.
So for an electron in one
region is 0 potential.
The other region
is a u0 potential.
And now I want to say, what
are the allowable energy
levels of this electron in
such a periodic potential?
This is my question.
So I will have to write
down the Schrodinger
equation for each region.
Between 0 and a,
the potential is 0.
And get a negative b to
0 is the potential u0.
So I have two different regions.
One is-- and minus
E psi equals 0.
And the other is--
so this is between--
for x, it's between a and 0.
The other is for x
between 0 and negative b.
And in that region, my
Schrodinger equation
is 2m d plus psi d x square
plus u0 minus E psi equals 0.
So I have two regions.
And, of course, I need
a boundary conditions.
In the end, what I'm
curious is still,
what are the energies
of the electron?
So we solved this type of a
problem in the last lecture.
And, here is, let's
say, 5 at a height.
Before we say,
potentially infinite.
So in that region, the
wave function is 0.
But now I have final u0.
So my wave function is
not 0 in this region.
So I'm going to
solve the first one.
Let's write the equation.
Yesterday I was using small k.
But today let me
switch to a capital
K. Capital K is K
square wave function.
So this is for this region--
for between 0 and a.
And K square is same location.
I want to find that
if I put this together
is 2mE divided by h bar square.
That's K square.
And I'm going to solve this.
You know the solution already.
So in this region, 0, a, my
wave function as function of x
is A exponential minus iK--
capital K x plus B exponential
plus i capital K x.
So this is one region that
I'm interested in, 0 to a.
The other region is
from minus b to 0.
If you look at the equation
there [INAUDIBLE] is
a plus, u0 minus E. Of course,
you can write that, also,
into [INAUDIBLE] here.
You can do the same.
But let me-- if my [INAUDIBLE]
Q square equals 2M u0
minus E divided by h square.
So K square is 2mE h square.
Now E is negative.
So my solution-- my root then
is a plus or minus [INAUDIBLE]..
It's another plus or minus iK.
That's the characteristic
equation for this one.
And then-- solution then
is exponential minus Qx
plus D exponential plus Qx.
You can write into
i if you reverse
E and the U, your choice.
It doesn't matter.
At the end, as long as you're
consistent after your mass,
you're fine.
So what I want to find
out is [INAUDIBLE] E.
This is my target.
What are the energy
of the electron?
It's an eigenvalue problem.
So I need to look
at the solution
and give a boundary
condition to the problem
so that I can solve for--
eventually I want
to solve for E.
So what are my boundary
between minus b to a?
The interface here between
the two region x equals 0--
there's a boundary.
At this location,
the wave function
itself has to be continuous.
And, also, I tell you the
derivative of wave function
has to be continuous.
And I'm not going to
demonstrate to prove it.
But, basically, if you say
your particle flux expression
that we had before--
if you require the particle
flux has to be continuous.
If your wave function
is continuous,
your derivatives also
has to be continuous.
So my-- either x equals 0,
what I have is this wave
function is continuous.
So on the two sides, the
wave function is continuous.
What do I have?
I have A plus B equals plus D.
Now you say I will require--
I will need four
boundary conditions.
And first order derivative
has to be continuous.
So what I have is iK
and minus A plus B--
that's the derivative
at x go towards 0--
equals Q minus C
plus D. Those are
the continuity at x equal to 0.
Now I have two
boundary conditions.
I need two more.
So this is where--
I mentioned at the beginning--
the Bloch theorem
start to kick in.
Why?
The problem is if I just write
this two boundary condition,
it's just a single interface.
It doesn't-- it has-- it
bears nothing to do with
the periodicity of the crystal.
Now, if you go back
to the potential--
the u potential is
a function of x.
Of course, in the problem we
have here is a step function.
We use a square.
So it's a step function,
in general, any arbitrary
function.
But it's a periodic
so ux equals u x
plus T. That's the periodicity.
So if you use this periodicity
and you go to the Schrodinger
equation, and you ask,
what does this periodicity
bring you to the solution?
What's the requirement
for your solution?
And then mathematically,
the Bloch Theorem--
Bloch proved that because of
this potential periodicity,
my wave function-- so
due to periodicity,
the wave function has to be--
after-- so wave
function x plus T later.
So one period later,
the same location
is related to the wave
function of x previous period,
same location, by ik times
T. So this k is a small k.
And that's the
Bloch Theorem here.
And, in fact, you can write
this in more general term.
And, so here-- this is a 1D.
And there are 3D version,
which we will comment later on.
And this small k
is a wave vector
that we'll discuss
more later on.
That's why I'm using
capital K for the solution
and to distinguish from
the small k with a vector.
So what does this tell us is,
I'm going to use a periodicity.
Now, I can look at this point--
this point.
And in the left-hand side is
my solution between 0 to a.
On the right-hand
side is this point.
This point is this one--
[INAUDIBLE]
And I have a solution for
this-- to this region.
I have a solution
for this region.
So I just need to relate
through this solution
through the Bloch Theorem.
So either x square to a,
I use the Bloch Theorem.
x equal to a, the
Bloch Theorem say
the wave function is related
and also corresponding.
You take a derivative.
Derivative is also related.
So the wave function is A--
in the first region, 0 to a--
you see, we have
that solution is
a exponential to minus
i capital A Ka plus B
exponential positive Ka.
And this equal to
exponential i k--
small k-- times T. That's
the T equals A plus B.
And then times the
wave function when
x equals to minus B. So
if I do x equals minus B
in that region, must be to 0.
So when x square
to it must be is
exponential Q of b plus D
exponential minus Q of b.
So I got my third equation.
And, similarly, if
I take a derivative,
I got my fourth equation.
So this is the wave
function, Bloch theorem,
and derivative,
Bloch theorem again.
So derivative is-- if
I take the derivative,
you can say they're equal.
So I have iKa and A exponential
minus exponential iKa plus B
exponential plus Ka--
this is a capital--
equals exponential minus iKT.
And you have a Q in the front
and minus exponential Qb plus D
exponential negative Qb.
We're not going to do more
operation of those four
equations.
The point I want to make is--
if you look at this, it's
a homogeneous equation,
no constant terms.
A, B, C, D-- you have
four coefficients.
And no constant terms
if you move to the one
side or constant is 0.
So this is the characteristics
of eigenvalue equations.
And you are-- if you have
a homogeneous equation,
to have a long zero solution--
A, B, C, D-- your determinant
must be 0 for linear equations.
Everybody's following me?
The determinant of--
1, 2, 3, 4 is 0.
If you say there's a determinant
0, you look at this--
capital K is a
function of energy.
K is a function of
energy E. And capital Q
is a function of energy.
So capital Q is a
function of energy.
So given the A, given the B--
we know T. And for each k, I
have a solution for energy.
So this is where my
math will end up.
So because this is a
homogeneous equation,
my determinant must be
0, the coefficients.
You put all your
coefficients together,
and you will get
an equation that
allow you to determine the
energy levels of the electron
in such a periodical potential.
So let me do a
few steps of math.
And if you do the
determinant, you
will actually will get an
equation not that scary--
is Q square minus K
square-- capital--
and a 2KQ sinh function--
hyperbolic sin-- Qb and sine--
real sine-- Ka plus cosh Qb
and the cosine capital K a.
On the right-hand side
is cosine small k--
that's a wave vector--
a plus b.
That's the periodical
at T. So this is the--
if you do your determinant of
this full equation, at the end,
you get this set of
equation, this equation here.
In this equation, Q has energy.
K has energy.
And small k-- so
for each k value,
you can solve for that
energy in the equation.
And this-- still, it's
not very graphical.
Mathematically, it's
still too complicated.
So let me make one
more simplification
for the purpose of
explaining this solution will
lead to the band
gap in the material.
The band gap is, essentially, if
you think about semiconductors
and all those.
So, my next step is
I let b close to 0.
But say, I will keep U times b--
because when that b is 0,
this is a very lateral--
b is [INAUDIBLE].
So this becomes very lateral.
And U times b finite.
That also means the potential
is going to shoot up very high.
But with this, if I say
b close to 0 Q times b,
this gets to just
approximate that Qb itself.
[INAUDIBLE] it.
So this-- by that,
the Q and Q cancel.
So what I have here, I
can write as P capital
K times a sine capital K times
a and plus cosine capital
K times a equals cosine ka.
Because b is 0.
So a, itself, is
the periodicity.
This is wave vector.
This K has the energy.
And the P, itself,
is just a constant.
P here is a constant.
So this one-- with this, I
can go say graphically what
this solution will look like.
You can say now, the
left-hand side is the cosine.
The maximum is the
minus 1 to plus 1.
The right-hand side--
I want to find the energy K.
And this capital K has energy.
Capital K is 2mE h square.
So you can say, this is
between minus 1 to 1.
And here is a factor--
when Ka goes to 1,
this divide this.
Sine x divided by x is 1.
So it's a P plus--
so this could be larger than 1.
In that case, there
is no solution.
There's no K-- capital K--
with the-- satisfy that.
So, graphically, If I do my
solution, what it looks like--
So what I'm going to
draw here on the--
is as a function of Ka.
So here I have K--
capital K-- a.
And because this is a little
bit difficult to solve.
So here is that function
on the left-hand side.
On the left-hand
side, it's just a--
you enter a decrease
into cosine.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: And on
the-- so this is Ka.
And on the right-hand side is--
the range is minus 1 to plus 1.
So because I want to find that
one other solution K for that
include energy-- so
this is the range
between minus 1 to plus 1.
I'm not drawing well.
So this is a positive 1.
This is negative 1.
So that means when K in this
region, I have solution.
In this region, I have solution.
But as the Ka becomes
larger, eventually, this
is within minus 1 to plus 1.
So I have a solution
everywhere when
this Ka becomes very large.
Ka means, again, energy.
So that means when
energy is very large,
I don't have forbidden region.
But in this region,
this is my forbidden--
I don't have any
energy in this region.
This region, I don't
have a solution.
So if I replot this--
because what I'm saying here
is, this region for any ka--
cosine the small k a--
if you gave me a values of
the cosine and small k a,
I have a corresponding
energy solution.
So I can go replot
that ka because this
is a periodical function.
So, now, this is a capital
K. That gives me energy.
My [INAUDIBLE] is I'm going to
plot this function in small k
a.
I hope you don't get confused.
I'm going to plot out what
the solution look like.
And the solution is say--
because this is a cosine ka--
so it's a periodic.
So my solution will
look like this.
And this is the energy.
And, essentially, what that
energy has is derived from k.
And so capital K a
is in this region.
That's [INAUDIBLE] solution.
And so this is a--
if in this region--
and in the next region,
I don't have energy.
This is a forbidden.
So I can't-- for the--
when in this region of energy
here, there's no solution.
So there is a gap here.
Because this is beyond the 1.
So what I have is [INAUDIBLE]
what it looks like.
So in between is a gap.
This is the gap that
I've been talking.
That's the corresponding
to this region here,
I have no solution,
no allowable energy.
Electrons cannot have
this energy when they put
in the periodic structure.
So this is my--
how the solution will look like.
And then let's leave
here and come back
to look at this wave vector.
What is the allowable
wave vector values?
So for the wave vector, I
have to go back to the--
here-- this is
the Bloch Theorem.
And so I need to decide,
what is the wave vector?
And I now-- I have for
any atoms in the crystal--
so between 1 and the
capital N, the total length
of the crystal--
L, the length of the
crystal is the N atoms
times the periodicity.
And this periodicity--
and the limit I'm consider
is N times a. a is my period.
Because b is 0.
So this is where there is
a very interesting boundary
condition, sort of artificial
boundary condition,
that was introduced.
And this boundary
condition is-- this is a 1.
This is an M. That's a
finite-length crystal.
There is a finite length.
And von Karman introduced a
periodic boundary condition.
Now I'm going to
write von Karman.
And what I say is--
because this N, capital
N, is usually very large,
it really doesn't matter much.
And the one way to do-- to say
a periodic boundary condition
is say, after this 1 to N, the
crystal will repeat itself.
So N plus 1 come back to 1.
So what is the
wave function for n
plus 1 equals the wave
function of 1 first atom.
And your real space
is going from 1 to N.
And this is called the von
Karman periodical boundary
condition.
And what does that
tell us is when--
so what we have here
is, when x equals n--
so what I have is
for psi x plus Na--
that's the length
of the crystal--
is equals psi x here.
And, with that, I will
have exponential ik times
Na should equal to 1.
So this is what from Karman
periodic boundary condition
gives me.
And it gives me a way to
say k equals 2 pi Na--
that's the length
of the crystal--
and times a small n.
And this n is plus or
minus 1, plus or minus 2,
and plus or minus n.
You continue.
Now, what it means is
this small k wave vector
is not a continuous function.
It has-- if you look at this n,
when error n equals the length
of the crystal--
when n equals capital
N and I have the ka--
k times a-- we'll
repeat the 2 pi.
k-- if you look
at that small k--
k times a, when n
equals to capital
n-- small n equal to
capital N-- that's 2 pi.
So here what I
have is, this is 0.
This is 2 pi.
And between ka-- between 0 and
2 pi, I have, really, endpoints.
So I will have--
the number of points
is N points here.
N is the number of
atoms in the crystal.
I think the other way
I want to say this--
from Karman periodic
boundary condition,
it really doesn't matter.
Basically, I have
electrons that extend--
the wave function can be
extended between 1 and n.
I have a wave function
in the region of 0
to L. Because I say
this is my beginning.
The [INAUDIBLE] L
is the total length.
So now I ask you, if you know
a function, whatever function,
between 0 and L--
x equals 0 to L--
and you know you can
do a Fourier series.
This is a finite lens function.
If you don't recall
your Fourier series--
if you have a function between
0 to L you write into Fourier
series sum, what is it?
Huh?
psi x-- any function
between 0 to L,
you can decompose
into the series
of sine and cosine functions.
So let's write that.
So I have, in
general, any function.
I can always write
a0 plus sigma n
equals 1 to infinite a
n cosine 2 pi n over L
x and plus bn sine 2 pi n L x.
That's any function-- as long as
I know this function between 0
to L, I can expand it in
sine and cosine series.
You agree?
So, what does this tell me?
If I write sine
cosine in exponential
is a n complex and
exponential i 2 pi n
L x plus bn complex and
exponential minus i 2 pi n L x.
I can rearrange and
write into exponential.
Once I write into exponential,
what does this mean?
This is the stationary part
of the Schrodinger equation.
You remember there is a
time-dependent exponential
minus i omega T. If I put
a minus i omega T into this
and multiply together,
this is a wave propagating
to the positive x direction.
This is a wave propagating
to the negative x direction.
So I'm decomposing this wave
function into many modes.
Again, the modes--
2 pi n L--
each n is one wave--
one wavelength.
So I'm decomposing
this into many modes.
And so what I have is, every
2 pi, I will have a capital--
a total [INAUDIBLE] endpoints.
And it's very important to
understand this [INAUDIBLE]..
So, basically, even though
this function I'm drawing
is continuous, and I have many
very closely spaced points,
as wave vectors.
And the total between 0 to
pi, say ka when at 0 to pi
is a capital endpoint states.
So this is the
representation in terms
of-- because it's periodic, so
now I have the option because I
don't want to draw all this.
So I can take a 0 to 2 pi.
I can draw this.
That's enough.
But say, even this
is not the easier way
to draw the band structure.
And, in fact, people don't
like to draw 0 to pi.
They like to draw 0 to pi
and the 0 to negative pi.
Any two pi is fine.
So I can draw, really, between
here and here, and forget
the rest.
And that's one.
And even this from--
from negative pi to positive
pi, again, there are endpoints.
0 to pi, they are endpoints.
And negative pi to the pi,
they are also endpoints.
But say it's a symmetric.
The wave going forward positive
x direction and negative x
direction-- they are symmetric.
That's why my solution positive
k [INAUDIBLE] is symmetric.
So because of that, I only
draw half, so 0 to pi.
So that's usually
what you say when
people plot the band structure.
And this-- what they'll say is--
they don't plot ka.
They will plot here, 0 to pi.
So this is pi over a.
That's a k wave vector.
And here is the energy.
And this is the solution
for whatever potential
in this specific periodicity
direction of the crystal.
All right.
I say it's a 1D crystal.
In real crystal, is
every direction you look,
you can say, OK I'm
considered the periodicity
in that specific direction.
And that's my wave vector.
That's why now it's a vector.
Wave vector direction is
along that specific direction
of the crystal.
And we will discuss
in the next lecture
more on the crystal geometries
and different geometry
of crystal.
Remember, here, because
there is a 0 to pi--
0 to pi only.
So there are really a 1/2 n,
n over 2 points, between 0
to pi away.
Because there are
another 1/2 is begin
on the other side, the negative
side, which I didn't draw.
So what does it-- what's
so special out of those--
[INAUDIBLE] electron
energy level.
And this is-- so you have
this semicontinuous curve.
The curve, itself,
you draw continuous.
But then because of
k is discontinuous,
this n is also
really closest space
about this continuous point.
What's the relation between
what we talked about for atomic
[INAUDIBLE] at the beginning.
And, roughly, this
bad is n equals 1.
If I think about the hydrogen
atoms, negative 13.6 n square.
And this band is n equals 1.
This n equals 2.
Now it's split into
many small levels.
And we see-- at the beginning
when we discuss hydrogen--
if I have any atoms,
I have energy levels.
Now I have endpoints
between negative pi
over a to plus pi over a.
So I have n energy level
in each of the span.
So, physically, it's a different
picture, different views.
But they are all the same thing.
Now, a few more
discussion here--
discussion point.
And first, we discuss
this small k with vector.
One is the-- this
[INAUDIBLE] crystal h bar k.
Remember, the
wave-particle duality
is h over [INAUDIBLE]
h bar over k times k.
And this is called
the-- in crystal,
it's called the
crystal momentum.
And without going
into detail, we can't.
This is the momentum
when you think
about doing the energy
conservation, momentum
conservation.
When two electrons
scatter with each other,
they still have to obey
energy conservation.
And they still have to obey
the momentum conservation.
And this is the momentum
that we'll be using.
And in 3D, k is a
vector that depends
on different
crystallographic directions.
And, also, we said that before,
this k and the k plus pi over a
are equivalent.
That's why we reduce this
periodical representation
into only between negative
pi over a to plus pi over a.
And what's really
striking is the gap.
From this, we say-- there
you say at this region,
there's no energy.
There's no electron
in the crystal
that can have those energy.
And like here,
similarly, there's
no electron in a crystal
that can have those energy.
So we have an energy gap.
And it turns out that
in real crystals,
we have many
different directions.
So maybe in one
direction is this way.
Maybe another direction,
the potential is different.
The periodicity--
this is a pi over a1.
Periodicity in that direction.
And maybe in the other
direction, is pi over a2.
So it's not a--
when I draw this, I'm drawing
in the other direction.
It's not a negative.
I'm just drawing in
the other direction.
And it might be even having
the possibility of this way.
And if I say in some
material it turns out
that there is a
gap no matter what.
consider all directions,
there is absolutely the region
where there is no energy.
And this is the band
gap of the material.
So energy gap and the extension
is 3D is the band gap.
Now, let's do a
little bit of counting
and to say, what does this mean?
So I take my hydrogen--
one-dimensional hydrogen
chain as example.
I put the electron--
so if I have a hydrogen chain,
one-dimensional hydrogen chain,
that's here.
And I have not add spin.
Now, I have to add spin.
Spin is afterthought.
Because my solution
doesn't include it.
So each energy level, in
fact, there is an s plus--
[INAUDIBLE] minus--
s 1/2 minus 1/2.
So there are two quantum state.
Now, I put the
electron-- electron
or with anything
except the humans,
like to go sit in the
lower energy state.
And [INAUDIBLE] biological
systems may not.
[INAUDIBLE] so I
put the electron
to go to a lower-energy state.
And if it's hydrogen--
so there are an electron.
Each hydrogen has one electron.
Between negative pi over
a to plus pi over a,
I have endpoints.
And that means I have
2n because of speed.
I have 2n quantum state.
So Pauli Exclusion
say each quantum state
has maximum one electron.
And, also, the Minimum Energy
Principle of Thermodynamics
say--
[INAUDIBLE] bring
in temperature.
But thermodynamics say the
electron goes to lowest energy
first.
So what happens is now I have
electron go here, go here,
go here, and fill in here.
Because it's 1/2.
I have 2n state.
I have n electrons.
So where electron fill to the
top, I say is-- this point
is the Fermi surface,
Fermi energy, Fermi level.
So we have Fermi level.
This is Ef.
And now, in just
a simple picture,
electron fill to the 1/2.
And now, if the
temperature is not 0,
electron gather kT energy.
Electron and the kT energy--
those electron maybe
will be located.
They don't move.
Those electrons near the Fermi
surface, they have energy kT.
And the energy separation
between these discrete small
levels are small enough
so the thermal energy can
make them move to other states.
So electrons can
move in the band.
So those are metals.
In metal, the Fermi level
force into the bands.
And in metal, not
every electron will be
contributing to the conduction.
AUDIENCE: What is so
special about Fermi levels?
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: What is--
PROFESSOR: Fermi level is
just a concept that will say,
if I fill in,
where's the topmost?
You fill in level in the bucket.
Where is that surface there?
That's where they
say those are--
so electron-- only electron
near the Fermi level
have a kT energy that
they can move around.
The electron way below
the Fermi level, kT--
the other stage isn't filled.
So Pauli Exclusion
Principle say, no way.
I don't allow you there.
So the electrons
in this region--
they don't contribute.
So even metal-- you
say you're going
to take a copper-- take a
lattice constant per unit
will have many electron.
But not all those
electrons will move,
will contribute to conduction.
Only the ones near
to the Fermi surface.
AUDIENCE: So the Fermi
surface has to be [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
I take the hydrogen example.
Now I'm going to
take a [INAUDIBLE]..
Now what happens if
I do [INAUDIBLE]??
Where is it?
So this is going to be here.
[INAUDIBLE] has two electrons.
So I have two n states.
I will fill to this region here.
What happened?
And that depends on
the gap here now.
kT is 26 million
electron volts--
26 million electron volts.
And if the gap is a few electron
volts, 5 electron volts--
so our field and the kT cannot
lift the electron to here.
There is a real
forbidden region.
Your electron cannot
have the energy.
So now you have a gap.
And this is the--
in that case, if the
gap is really large--
let's say 5 electron volts--
it's an insulator.
It's a dielectric.
It's an insulator.
You look like glass--
the glass is an insulator
because there is
a really large gap, energy gap.
So photons-- with both
photon, the 0.5 micron.
1 micron is 1.24.
[SIGHS] I can't
remember which is which.
1 electron is 1.24 micron.
Or the 1/2--
[INAUDIBLE] 0.5 microns is about
2-some electrons-- electron
volts.
2 electron volts-- the
gap is much larger.
So the light will transmit
through the window.
They [? can't ?] lock the
electron from here to here.
They don't have enough energy.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For semiconductors,
where the Fermi levels
[INAUDIBLE] did--
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: --in the
[INAUDIBLE] gap--
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's-- you're jumping.
AUDIENCE: How so?
PROFESSOR: Good.
Good question.
I'm not-- so I have to go to
more talk about semiconductors.
So semiconductor
gap is typically
about 1 to 2 electron volts.
And in that case, there are
some of the thermal energy--
even though it's 26
million electron volts--
I have not talked
about the [INAUDIBLE]----
I mentioned [INAUDIBLE] Factor.
So there is a distribution of
that energy-- thermal energy.
Some electrons have
enough thermal energy--
very few-- they can jump
if they have enough energy.
Similarly, they can be
locked from here to here.
So what happens--
I'm talking about--
that's a 1D example.
Here is 3D.
It's the same.
I have a gap.
So some electrons can be
locked from here to here
because if they have--
if those electrons have
enough high energy
compared to the gap.
So what's going to leave behind?
If I have [AUDIO OUT]
One more step.
1, 2 helium.
Go to the next one, lithium.
it's 3 electron.
It has to go to
here, the next band.
And so the Fermi
level don't have
to be lowest to [INAUDIBLE].
It's just-- so
you have to fill--
you look at the periodic table.
You fill to the topmost.
There are many bands.
And so when we have the--
let's say I'll take
the simpler one.
And it turns out sometimes--
this is the lowest.
This is the highest.
It depends on-- this is a k.
This is where I draw k.
I'm drawing a small region.
I can be drawing here.
So, now this is my band gap.
This is the EG, silicon EG.
What is silicon EG?
AUDIENCE: 0.1.
PROFESSOR: 1.1,
1.12 electron volts.
What's a gallium arsenide?
AUDIENCE: 1.6.
PROFESSOR: 1.4.
So now I have some
thermal energy.
So what happens is some
electron [INAUDIBLE] normally,
will be locked from lower
energy to higher energy.
So what it left behind
is some empty states.
So now I have some empty states.
And I have some filled states.
And this is a conduction band.
This is a valance band.
Conduction band, valence band--
valence band has
some empty states.
And electrons are now
suddenly in this band.
Again, because the energy
is so close to each other,
those electrons can move around.
And this electrons
fill to the top.
Now, originally, if I had 0
temperature, they fill here.
They can't move.
But now [INAUDIBLE] some
temperature, room temperature--
there's some empty
space left behind.
So this electrons-- now they can
move around those empty states.
Most of those electrons
here are sitting here.
They don't move.
So it's a one stone, two birds.
The electron move
from here to here.
The electron can move here.
The empty states also make
the rest electron happier.
When your lab is too crowded,
that's the situation, right?
[CHUCKLES] The guys who
are moving to a bigger room
are happy.
And the guys left
behind, also happy.
That's what happens to a lab.
And so those empty states--
it's better than-- rather
than majority of the electron
moving to empty states, the
opposite is there's holes.
So it's a positive charge.
So there's no hole.
It's just a charge.
It's easier to describe
these empty states as holes.
And this is the electron.
So we have valence band--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [SIGHS]
--conduction band--
conduction band or valence band.
And this is a valence.
So you can say that
you have to really go
to quantum to understand
even the basic-- why
there is an insulator?
Why there is a conductor?
Why there is a metal?
And now, I thought that--
I'm debating whether
I show the slide
or go to do our
weekly exercise--
going to the website
or going to continue.
But now let me-- just--
because I think I
need to finish this.
So I'm going to skip that.
This is the intrinsic
semiconductor.
There's always an equal
number of electron holes.
Because if one
electron go up, it
will leave behind a
hole, empty state.
Now, most of the time you don't
work with just the intrinsic.
You actually [INAUDIBLE]
So what do you do?
You put in silicon--
if you look at silicon,
it has 4 electrons.
You put in phosphor--
so silicon has a periodic
structure, 4 electron.
They all happy.
Now, rather than silicon,
you put the phosphor here.
Now it's a 5.
The actual electron can
detach from phosphor
and become commonly shared.
And so, basically, the
energy level of the phosphor
is somewhere here.
The thermal energy is
so hot-- is large enough
to lift this electron from
phosphor to the conduction
band.
So, in that case, you
can put a-- you dope it.
That's called doping.
You artificially
put the dope in.
You put the phosphor.
That's an [INAUDIBLE].
You put a boron,
which has 3 electron.
What that does, though, it turns
out boron energy level is here.
And then say the
electron is so happy
to say a closed energy level.
Once-- so you will fill here.
You will say kT, so
leave behind empty state.
So you have holes.
So you dope.
You borrow a dope.
You get a [INAUDIBLE] You
double phosphor, you get n time.
So that's the semiconductor.
That's an extreme thing.
So we have the difference
between extrinsic--
that's a [INAUDIBLE].
And the intrinsic is
when you don't dope it.
And intrinsic, in fact--
sometimes it's hard to make.
When you purify silicon,
you can make that pure.
And gallium arsenide, who have
semi-insulating substrate when
you [INAUDIBLE],, that's because
[INAUDIBLE] band gap is 1.4,
is higher than 1.1.
And so there is a very few
electrons intrinsically
if you try to purify
even though you'll still
have some impurities.
There's another big difference.
Here, when I have--
I draw here between
here and here,
if the gap is happening
in different directions--
you have to look at
different directions.
I'm going to talk more
of this directionality.
If this is not at
the same point--
this is the momentum,
k momentum here.
Electron-- hole momentum--
electron is here--
goes there and need
a different momentum.
There's a change.
So that's an indirect
semiconductor.
Silicon is an indirect
And in a lot of cases,
it turns out, also,
the minimum and maximum
is the same place.
That's a direct
gap semiconductor.
Gallium arsenide
has a direct gap.
So it turns out the light
doesn't have much momentum.
If you think about them--
h over lambda-- lambda
for light is 1/2 micron.
For crystal, a is
a lattice constant.
It's a [INAUDIBLE].
So photon momentum
is very small.
So when it's a direct
gap, you can easily
excite because the momentum
conservation is easier because
of vertical transmission.
No momentum needed.
But in silicon, that's
not easy because it's
going from here to here.
It needs that momentum.
So it's an indirect
semiconductor.
And that's why
the light source--
lasers are made of
gallium arsenide.
But always the
people want to say,
can I make a light
source with silicon?
Because silicon is so
good for electronics.
It's not good for optics.
And that's also a reason why--
silicon doesn't absorb well.
So when you make
a solar cell, you
have to make it
very [INAUDIBLE]..
Because the chance
of light, again,
when it gets into the crystal--
get absorbed is not good.
So you make it thicker
to increase that chance.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you decide
between [INAUDIBLE] hydrogen,
for example?
Where's the [INAUDIBLE]
when you [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Hydrogen [INAUDIBLE]
my simple 1D picture--
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: --this is here.
So it's a metal.
I don't even call it the
valence of conduction.
It's a metal.
This is my conduction band.
And helium here-- then if
I-- electron go from here,
then this the valence.
This is conduction.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So the highest [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Highest
occupied-- yeah, in fact,
when you do molecule, this
is called Highest Occupied
Molecular Orbital.
So when you do, say,
plastic solar cells--
so there are people talk
about HOMO and LUMO.
Because the wave functions--
the wave vector is--
the energy is no longer--
this continues.
It's a sort of discrete--
your language,
actually, was official.
CuMo and LUMO-- the Highest
Occupied-- the Highest Unoccu--
Lowest Unoccupied.
OK?
I'll make up for this
slide [INAUDIBLE]
looking at journals next week.